well especially given there's no
increments so there's no help coming
right this is like a
this is a wild west style affair
[Music]
well even though i'm not really sure how
rain would feel about being cast as the
sith hicaro this is some pretty good
pretty good fan artwork here right yeah
it's really really well done you see
rain here you see sardo's you see kevin
board you see um
you see chiyu uh then there's yoda i'm
not quite sure who yoda is exactly
but um there's yoda here too um and uh
and it is it is chess wars and we are
ready to roll i think sardo send it up
his
final prayers to the chess god save your
breath sardosh i've been praying to the
chess gods for years look where it's
gotten me
viva la france that's what that's all
i'm going to say i bet everything on
i just bet everything on sardo so he
better not let me down
okay well um picard have you ever prayed
to the chess guys did they answer your
prayer or not mine is that what happened
um no i mean generally i don't do that i
i think the only thing i will say is
that sometimes there are some
superstitions i have you know i think
i've noticed sardosh has al has worn the
same shirt right
yeah i think he's worn the same shirt
during every match so he does i don't
maybe he just wears the same shirt every
day because i mean we know there's a
certain
other uh french-speaking streamer who
does that so maybe maybe i mean starters
is trying to try just just trying to
model after him
but i do think sargeras has worn the
same shirt for every match i i
we should ask him afterwards especially
if he wins if that's the reason it's
because he's uh he's superstitious
now i was a3 is a good move by by ray
now i think i'm kind of curious to see
will starters go back to e7 or will they
go to a5
and actually in a way i kind of prefer
a5 i think it's a little bit easier
um to get the bishop to b6 it feels like
the peace placement is pretty good for
for black here
this is a nervous moment for rayne
wilson where he's he's
he's nearing two minutes taken on the
clock and still hasn't played
the only move oh oh he plays knight c5
it's still
it's it's a good move it's still a move
though he can play the other order i
would have traded them on knight c5 he
can still do it this way too though
and sardoche with knight to b4 this is a
big moment this could be the game right
here if rain doesn't solve this problem
correctly jakarta
absolutely and i'm not surprised that
sardosh found it it was it was a move
that was sort of screaming to be played
and um and now for rain he has to find
which rook square to
where to move his rook rookie 2 is
actually a great move by the way
fantastic move so sardo should
should look to take advantage of the a
file here even something like bishop b5
and offering the trade that's one of the
fastest ways to take advantage of
disconnected pieces but he plays nicely
too
again not so clear though because black
can take and go rook a2 it still
still is unclear so that and that's the
other thing i would say is so
i would feel like more at the
intermediate level or beginner level if
there's an open file i think
actually having a rook against the
bishop tonight generally is preferable
um because it's a lot easier to just use
the world versus coordinating the bishop
in the night
now um seize it and now it gets spicy
this is going to get super spicy sardosh
might even end up because
at less experienced levels everyone even
though the night and bishop are
objectively better look at what's
happening rain is rain is not
it's it's wait he didn't play what what
whoa
what yeah they're both just missing g4
it's hanging what are they doing
what the g4 is hanging on the board
oh my gosh what is going on here oh man
that was
and now he now he almost is losing the
pieces
i think sardo's just panicked i honestly
think sergio is just panicked there he
saw his clock was getting low and he
just panicked yeah
wow he just missed his winning
opportunity we didn't think we'd see
evil bar swings like that but now
if right right if rayne finds the plan
of getting the knight in then white
should still be winning but he's already
missed it a few times and in fact here
you go again
what i was trying to say is it's so much
harder to coordinate the knight and
bishop for less experienced players than
it is to play with the rook and
we're seeing that here even though
reigns better he's not coordinating the
miners the way
you know a master would obviously yeah
that's the thing it's like because you
think about it it's two-for-one
yeah and now you don't take the bishop
on e1 it's important just like
water is broke oh my god oh my gosh
if sardocia had taken the pawn or given
check he might have come back and won
that game you panicked
you know it was like sir dosh i think
it's just too much too much in the way
of nerves he was defending for so long
yeah that when he had the opportunity
just he eventually cracked under the
pressure of the situation
but let's see let's see um yeah yeah
just knight takes pawn
very rough very rough for um for sara
dosh i mean like
he he he really kept it together but i
think it was just the comb it was the
pressure of being worse on the board
and the pressure of the clock as well
and just it got to him
he just couldn't keep it together past a
certain point um and it was like
right when he was back it was right when
it turned around the wonder occurred
um so i yeah you know i think i think
it's just one of those things where
i don't even know how you're supposed to
look at it because he's done this twice
now with the backwards night capture but
maybe there's just some way
to just double double check and see i
don't see where your night is or
something i'm not i'm not really sure
how he can do it but the fact that it's
not the first time is
is um is a bad sign yeah
yeah well and he he had gotten himself
in a position where the rook was
was flexing on the knight and bishop and
reign and we talked about
sardosh missing the opportunity but you
know reign was going backwards
with the pieces and the knight and
bishop were not doing what they were
supposed to so
really unfortunate to see sardosh miss
the the night capture and
unless rain pulls uh let's rain pulls a
stalemate here
oh my god when you play 25 for a second
i thought he did
oh man look at the sardosh oh man yeah
well i mean
i mean we all we all knew it was it was
a good job yesterday that's all i'm
gonna say
reign's approach in general is he just
kind of wants to get to the middle game
he's not into the opening stuff so
that's why
most of my opening advice is how not to
lose
um
is it going to play the hippopotamus
with e6 and 97.97 oh wow
this this is the thing rain loves but
this is gonna this could get him in big
trouble and i think this might have been
what kevin was coaching
sardoshan like look if he gives you the
center take it and don't apologize
yeah exactly so um
yeah i mean pretty pretty balanced
position white has much more space in
the center of the board it's
very hard to play here um for both sides
i feel like because neither side really
has a clear break
um black can't play e5 like black
normally does uh
f5 is probably too dubious because of
knight q5 so it's going to be
interesting to see
um how rain how rain reacts here it's
also going to be really important that
sardosh keeps it together though he's
really got to stay focused
um and i think not fall too far behind
on the clock so i think the clock is
really what hurt him the most in the
first game
this is a pawn that while it looks good
could end up being a disaster for rain
exactly i mean again i think for
starters plays queenie too great move
as long as starters keeps it together
here and he doesn't doesn't panic and
freak out too much
he still is has a very good chance to
win this game
yeah the risk of d5 ray might play d5
but the risk is then the dark squares
are problematic and you've got new
problems
again it's anyone's game though i feel
like i i feel like the the the
the uh the weakness of the black king
here gives sardosh good chances
regardless
even though even though objectively it
was a bad move uh oh he's got rook c6
he's got rook c6 okay
six huge well he also cuts off the queen
from b5 by the way which is officially a
threat for black
yeah rook c6 is a huge move will he find
it
if he finds rookie i think he's going to
win this game
what a move this is it well sardo's play
rook takes he does
nice i think i think we're headed to
overtime
oh what is that oh no what is that by
rain
yeah oh well now rain just loses rick
takes rook and you just
oh and now you resign now you just
resign
so this was super tough for it was super
tough for raymond because of how
sardoche played it i mean honestly he
kept the pressure
rook c1 wasn't as good as knight d2 but
in hindsight the idea was just as strong
and and he's gonna take this wow
yeah you know i was gonna say that um a
lot of credit goes to sergio she kept it
together like you could tell he was
really frustrated when he hung that pawn
on c4
um there are a lot of movements and
gesticulations and all those other
things
but he kept it together and he didn't
completely lose it and he still made
moves
logical moves didn't spend too much time
um and he's gonna he's gonna win this
game now i think
well we called it then we said that's
going to be a pawn that he's happy is
gone look at the c
file it's winning in the game now
queenie five maybe
25 yep yeah and that's all she wrote
very nice finish
got nervous there for like a second i
mean if if rainey got here i don't know
what would have happened
yeah but yeah yeah he's got he's gonna
win now especially because as i said
before it's a bishop
i don't think he's speaking english or
french he's speaking
yeah the good thing is that it's a
bishop it's a bishop so bishop can only
attack on you know the dark dark colored
tiles
and therefore uh there's no chance of of
sardosh not winning here it's like 99.99
percent guaranteed he will win
so we're gonna head to uh to blitz gonna
be blitz overtime where i think sort of
has to be the favorite um i believe
there it does matter who gets who gets
white and i believe sardosh will get
white i think it is decided by rating
but we'll confirm that so
um wow
yeah there's just no way because i as
i've noticed if you get a bishop that's
the one
end game where your tricks even even if
even in the consolation bracket if you
end up with like a rookie against a
bishop the bishop just does not
attack you can only attack on one color
of squares so
it's it's not it's it's not you just you
can't create threats with a bishop
so there's just no way that sardosh
doesn't win sir dosh
cleans this up i'll uh i'll clean up
what was a discussion
for the community just so you know the
donations were coming in so fast that
the animation fell behind
the bar so just so you know a lot of the
donations flashing now
that we already shot out and i and i
gave a shout out to you before you were
not being ignored just you guys got way
ahead of the animation
so um so it took a while to catch up but
again
uh thank you to everyone and i think
we're going to have overtime so
on poisson right on cue there's on
poisson and then you know you see the
lolly checkmate on b7 yep but the
bar is accurate in real time just so you
know the bar is accurate for donations
just like uh it takes a frenchman to not
miss on
not win uh miss on poisson right of
course
okay i think sardosh is probably gonna
go right back to it with some kind of
improvement from kevin if i had to guess
yeah i would definitely agree with that
all right so here we go
now once again this is 5-0 so it's it's
and the other thing i would say is i
suspect that uh
that sardosh has not played much blitz
because his rating is one thousand and
four where his reign is 1385 but but
then again reign is 13.85
is that based on a significant
significant amount of games or just like
one or two is also it's only based on
one or two and his in his main account
he's about 11
50. so okay um he's
you know what that's based on it's based
on basically whatever armageddon games
he's had here in this event
um which he's won every tiebreaker
right that's true yep okay so let's see
okay so bishop e2 well sardo's go d4 is
a big question mark too yeah d4 is going
to move
well i think it's an e447 right
okay this should be seven completely
reasonable so far
i will say i think this this opening is
a little bit favorable to black because
i feel like white's ideas are not
so obvious here if white doesn't play d4
and four's open this diagonal like if
white goes d3 i think blacksmiths are a
little bit easier with like rookie 8 and
bish buffet
pretty dicey already for rain down a
minute on the clock
um well especially given there's no
increments so there's no help coming
right this is like a
this is a wild west style affair
especially when you were just playing a
bunch of increment
it's hard to make that adjustment but at
the same time both of these guys have
had tie breakers
and right for sardosh it took a tie
breaker to get here
you know so um we know that they know
what's in store
right so now will rain finally play d4
the last moment that he can play d4 will
he do it
will he do it if he doesn't starters
goes d4 and you open up the long
diagonal and you excavate the knight on
f3 and the pawn on g2
yeah so he does go d4 good move
yeah the this if rayne doesn't play 95
here i think he's probably gonna lose
okay he does but he's had two moments
had to find 95 and he found him both
times but
again two minutes on the clock
yeah i mean i think for rain this is
this is really hard to play because the
bishop on b2 is bad
black has the obvious lever with f6 to
remove that knight from e5
um and the queen and bishop also are on
c7 and d6 which are lined up very neatly
here
yeah i want to see if starters finds f6
here which is a very good yeah f6 or
even c3 first are both really good but i
think f6 is just
kind of you know yeah i don't i don't
want to say obvious but when you just
move the knight it's got to be on his on
his agenda and indeed sardosh finds it
this guy this guy has just gotten so
good over this last month and he's
playing this blitz game like a boss
yeah it's it's really weird it's like
when sardo doesn't have time to think
when he doesn't let his
his like mind like start to you know
mess with his confidence he just plays
free-flowing chess
he plays a lot better and i think that's
actually true of a lot of people the
last time they had to think and start
like
being insecure and worrying about this
or that the the better they play when
they just can't think it's just like
they just move
you just play the game you don't let
your brain like disturb you and
and mess up everything
well now rain is really getting down on
the clock and this is probably going to
be
the story not not even just because of
the clock but he's also much worse on
the board so it would take a blunder by
sardosh probably to give rain chances
yeah c3 here is very strong i think d3
and knight she five but
oh knight d5 oh no he blundered
does reigns see it knight
this is his last chance it's gonna come
down to the wire
but now king oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
all the way back perhaps the most epic
and wild ending
you could ask for in an overtime
tiebreaker a surprise checkmate but
before we get into that
good news for you both community rally
got us over fifty thousand dollars so
matched with a hundred thousand by
chess.com
we have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars going to charity
and a lot of it was driven on this last
day so amazing
amazing stuff thank you guys and
tell us more just about you know how
much you enjoyed playing the event your
your you know how much you love chess
and you know how was this experience
playing in pogchamps
this event sucked chess sucks
france sucks
no man uh this is a lot of fun man it
was
listen i'm an old i'm an old dude and i
was for a little while on the high
school chess team
wasn't very good um but to get to dive
in
and re-examine the game in a fresh way
was a lot of fun
and i'm really excited for the money
that we made
uh for our non-profit sardosh if you
want to donate any of your winnings over
to our charity
you're welcome my friend um and played
some great players along the way had a
great experience
and um thrilled to be a part of it and
just big congratulations to sartosh on
his
victory sardosh same question to you
just tell us
your final thoughts on playing in pog
champs and uh and where
where you're going from here with your
with your chess career
um first of all out of all my esport
career i played some great league of
legends tournaments
i played some great twitch rewards on
many games but
out of everything that that was the win
i was the most happy with
like i i i will actually
fade out when i won this game it was too
much to under
i never felt something like this this
this
it has been like two months i'm
literally discovering the game and
getting obsessed with it and i play like
maybe 12 hours a day for like two months
so i'm i'm doing for four hours of
puzzle you can
make it like it i i went to 2100 and
like i play
six hours again every day just sometimes
never get out of my bed and pay my phone
uh that was something i really was
focused on so i'm so proud i want it and
i know i will chill a bit i will i will
focus on another thing i will play a bit
of forget league and stuff like this
but i will never forget chess and play
it's until i get at least two thousand
sometimes and i mean who can say i eat
those levels some
some day in my life i think that will be
a really good
life goal and i will definitely am for
it at some point here
[Music]
and play on the board by the way would
be awesome
yeah i don't think i've ever done
anything for 12 hours a day so that's
pretty incredible and you earned it man
thank you guys both so much and again
thank you to the community
who came through in the clutch and got
us over that 150
000 raised marker and the two largest
percentages
going to reign in sardosh's uh charities
respectively but remember all of the
participants get
a percentage to the charities that they
chose which is incredible so
guys what a wild ride thank you so much
for doing this congratulations to you
both congrats sardoche
and uh maybe a future pog champs and
we'll see you then
what a what a pog champs way to end it
with a 92 surprise checkmate on the
board
yeah it was i mean it was a great finish
it's sort of that game swung back and
forth the whole match swung back and
forth
the way that he took it so seriously and
then it comes through win that second
game then win the tiebreaker i was just
really really special
so sardosh that the hard work paid off
and an incredible and deserving
pogchamps champion there
you